let's bring in House Minority Leader
Kevin McCarthy leader McCarthy I thought
that you guys going to take the Senate
bill and just to basically make some
minor changes and run just stamp it but
as Nancy Pelosi gonna start from scratch
no she's not she's playing political
games and she never should have said
that there is nobody in the house here
but Nancy and I myself
she cannot craft another bill time is of
the essence people will lose their job
today because of what a Schumer and the
others are portraying and doing we are
closer than we had been I was in the
meeting yesterday with the four leaders
this is a different process you know
what Mitch McConnell did he did from the
bottom up he had Democrats and
Republican senators together actually
working out the bill it was the leaders
who came in and stopped this process and
what what Senator Schumer is complaining
about his resources provided to
companies to keep employees hired to me
this is the lowest level look at the
difference of what we just saw a couple
weeks ago in the house when when we
didn't get to work with Nancy Pelosi our
own members and craft a bill but when we
finally got the bill we were able to
make the changes to it even the language
was not correct late into the night
but I moved the bill forward because I
wanted America to see us working
together to give us hope that we can do
this and on a handshake we said we would
fix that bill on Monday the technical
changes what the senators did last night
it wasn't even voting on the bill they
had 30 more hours they were simply
moving the process forward to give this
country hope to show that they can work
together this is uncalled for this is
going to do damage to us and it is
unacceptable the country does not want
us to be partisan they want us to be
productive and that is what we did in
the minority over on this side and that
is what we expect to happen over there
but they had more input than any other
time I wish we had that type of input
when we would craft a bill well I tell
you what a leader McCarthy I don't know
if your ears were burning just about a
half an hour ago but Newt Gingrich who
once upon a time was Speaker he
mentioned you and talked a little bit
about what's going on right now to the
Republic
and via the Democrats listen to this
what you have now is a power struggle
where Pelosi and Schumer believe they
can blackmail the president into
accepting and really dumb ideas again I
think there are some things you
negotiate some things you can work out
but I personally do not want to see a
Trump McConnell McCarthy team that are
blackmailed by Pelosi and Schumer and
given I think the American people need
to understand we can get something done
immediately this week the house has to
come back to do it but they ought to put
a lot of pressure on Pelosi and Schumer
to put America ahead of partisanship so
leader McCarthy is that what's going on
are they blackmailing your side that's
exactly what they're trying to ask for
if you said in that room yesterday with
these four leaders the things that they
were asking for they want to talk about
election law they want to talk about
money that was going to places think for
one moment what we were able to do
before we've sent more money to the
state we increased the funding level
there that we found time to work
together this is actually to protect the
jobs to provide more resources for what
we need in dealing with this situation
time is of the essence but what's so
critical here is the actual senators
Democrats and Republicans got together
and crafted the bill it is the
leadership that has come in because
they're unhappy that they couldn't craft
it themselves this is the way our
founders believed we should have written
the bill and for them to hold up any
process of moving forward is not even
voting on the bill it's giving the 30
hours of debate to start moving Chuck
Schumer should allow the American public
to be able to move forward and this is
unacceptable
Nancy Pelosi says the house will
introduce its own its own bill listen to
what she said
they are so far apart
because that's their deadline for a vote
but we'll be introducing our own bill
and hopefully it'll be compatible with
what they discuss in the Senate so No
Deal that's bipartisan at this point
already
that is exactly what Newt Gingrich was
talking about she has no bill she has no
people she has no members that was a
political ploy to try to give cover to
Schumer to get his Democrats to vote no
this is a moment in time that those
Democrat senators should not sit back
and take the direction of leadership put
the American public first yes but Kevin
here's what they say specifically you do
a lot of great things number one giving
money to small business and saying if
you use this money to keep your
employees paid you can take this as a
grant if you fire your employees it is
alone and then you said for two years I
don't want these corporations buying
their stock back the Democrats said I
want it longer than two years so and
they also want more money to hospitals
and more money to States I mean is there
something is there a gray area you guys
can dive into there what is the main
objection from what I just said well
listen we have the research the biggest
challenge you have for small business is
liquidity why because we asked as a
government that you had to shut down to
help our health we should allow those
people to help them during this bridge
gap and most importantly we want people
to continue working we increase
unemployment insurance here if someone
has get laid off but what we're really
doing is helping the small business stay
afloat pay their employees and pay their
rent we're doing the same thing on every
business as we go forward that is what
you need you want people to stay working
and I know for the Democrats to hold
this up we're providing more money to
the states we're providing more money to
healthcare we're moving the things that
we need to get done but they're holding
it up while they could still negotiate
for the next 30 hours there are very few
things that divide them on this because
Democrats and Republicans wrote this
bill together what is holding them up is
the attitude of leadership that somehow
they are not getting credit for the
is a moment in time that you should step
back and put the American public first
before you want your own little title on
it leader McCarthy let me ask you about
this over on the Senate side five
Republicans are out because they are in
self quarantine and Rand Paul tested
positively going forward is the house
thinking about how to remotely vote or
how will government run if if people are
sick look we will figure that out we
have a different options talking to the
speaker about that ways that we can get
this vote forward but that even points
to a bigger problem right here why would
the Democrats hold it up in a moment of
time that more people are getting sick
the continuity of government you want to
keep together and we will but what's
more importantly the the millions of
Americans out there that need our help
today put put your own ambitions aside
and put America first let's solve this
problem let's move the system forward
and allow the debate to continue to sit
back and say no are put this belief that
the house is going to start crafting
that would be too late and too little
and we would look back in history at
this moment of time and look at the
damage that was created just because of
a personality of an individual wanted
some hot type of credit are to leverage
something a little further this is not a
time for partisanship this is a time for
us to be productive just as we showed
the Republicans inside this house that
we voted on a bill that did not have the
language that we agreed to because we
put this country first because we did it
on a handshake that we would solve it
later and it was that is not happening
in the Senate while they had more input
than we've ever seen before
all right leader McCarthy thank you so
much for being with us stay strong